et maintenant c'est l'heure deux grilles
en 2017
[Musique]
pour la troisième fois en quelques
semaines et ce sera la même chose le
week-end prochain il est interdit de
parler politique à la télévision une
règle édictée par le csa comme vous le
savez l'influencent des humoristes dans
ce pays est énorme et la moindre vannes
de ma part une simple blagounette
pourrait influencer dangereusement le
vote des français
interdire aux humoristes de parler
politique à la veille d'un scrutin alors
que depuis des mois le csa autorise nos
politiques à faire les clowns sur toutes
les chaînes de télévision c'est
globalement injuste
[Applaudissements]
que faire donc lorsqu'on est humoriste
politique et qu'on n'a pas le droit de
parler politique pouvais je ne pas venir
déserté abandonné le public de ses huit
déjà
déjà meurtri par les très nombreuses
affaires qui secoue depuis quinze jours
sont babar nationale alors qu'un gérard
dupire animateurs de l'année vient de
lui être décerné son quatrième je me
devais d'être là on ne quitte pas un
navire en pleine tempête s'est vite
c'est avant tout une famille une famille
recomposée avec des oncles et des tantes
bizarre quand je dis tente n'y voyez
aucune connotation homophobe des cousins
germains des pièces rapportées
d'anciennes gloires des cagoles de
futurs chômeurs mais ça reste une fête
ne pas venir suite été trahir donné
raison au csa ne baisse jamais les bras
tu risque de le faire deux secondes
avant le miracle nous avons sur ce
plateau deux dinosaures de la télévision
deux exemples de ténacité et de
persévérance
mesdames et messieurs thierry ardisson
et christophe dechavanne
dechavanne 34 hommes métier l'homme a
survécu à tous la privatisation francis
bouygues la télé réalité et même assez
divorce
le macgyver dupes a percuté un été par
une mobylette à bali christophe est
toujours là être percutée par une
mobylette à bali un accident qui
arrivent principalement aux gens payant
lisf les insoumis eux sont généralement
percuté par des scooters à la courbe
[Applaudissements]
inoxydable christophe aujourd'hui encore
nouveau succès sur tf1 avec the roll mur
de joie ou des lamentations oui oui il
ne faut jamais baisser les bras surtout
en cette période de transfert de mercato
télévisuel où les rumeurs les plus
folles circulent david pujadas sur lci
william leymergie sur ces huit daphné
bürki sur france 2 enora malagré sur
sur sur la touche
il faut y croire non
il faut y croire même morandini pourrait
retrouver du travail peut être pas
animateur sur télétoon auguri les
tentations serait trop grande mais un
poste de chroniqueur sur vivolta où la
moyenne d'âge est de 60 ans est
sérieusement envisagée
je me devais d'être là oui mais pour
quoi faire telle est la question date et
de quoi acheter
être ou ne pas être là est la question
y at il plus de noblesse à souffrir les
couleurs les outrages d'une destinée
désinvolte qu'à prendre les armes contre
cet océan de douleur et y mettre fin
d'une définitive révolte nourrir dormir
rien de plus et par le sommeil sonné le
glas des mots du coeur et des 1000
chocques reçues mourir dormir rêvait
peut-être
au passage un grand merci à pascal
sevran pour sa participation merci
pascal
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi citer hamlet de shakespeare à
ce moment précis de ma chronique
pourquoi infliger un tel personne au
public de ces huit un public déjà
meurtri je les dis principalement pour
la beauté de la langue mais aussi soyons
honnêtes pour gagner trois minutes sur
cette chronique
comment faire pour réussir ce challenge
sept épreuves imposées par le csa tenir
dix minutes sans parler politique après
trois jours passés à me morfondre sur
une feuille blanche mardi soir une idée
m'est venue suite à l'agression d'un
policier sur le parvis de notre-dame je
me suis dit pourquoi ne pas faire une
reprise de la chanson de claude françois
si j'avais un marteau
[Musique]
daniel ou
et la nuit
j'y mettrai tout mon coeur
surtout les policiers
mais jean bart
sur toutes les forces de l'ordre
de coup droit tout
ces célibataires
cautionne pas
pas du meilleur goût j'en conviens mais
voilà à quelles extrémités le csa et son
règlement inepte peuvent conduire
évidemment j'entends d'ici vos
commentaires
demandez à guillon d'écrire une
chronique sans politique ça n'a pas de
sens c'est antinomique mais là là je
poserai un bémol il y a parfois de
bonnes surprises souvent quand des
artistes des sportifs s'essaye à une
autre activité que leur activité de
prédilection cela donne de petites
merveilles de véritables pépites qui se
souvient aujourd'hui du yannick noah
vainqueur de roland garros en 83
personnes en revanche on se souvient
tous du sublime saga africa écrit huit
ans plus tard saga africa ambiance de la
brousse saga africa attention les
secousses après shakespeare c'est
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
les exemples sont nombreux que dire de
bernard tapie homme d'affaires médiocre
mais inoubliable interprète de
commissaire valence voilà voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour toutes ces raisons ce papier
à politique restera lui aussi dans les
annales de la télévision
les dix minutes sont écoulées sauvés par
le gong à la semaine prochaine merci
et tout cela sous
c'est
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu